[Music]
the newest royal baby officially has a
name and let's just say a former one
Directioner approves my thing is for
this pretty impressive Kate Middleton
and Prince William revealed their third
child's name on Friday releasing in a
statement from Kensington Palace quote
the Duke and Duchess of Cambridge are
delighted to announce that they have
named their son Louis
Arthur Charles the baby will be known as
His Royal Highness Prince Louis of
Cambridge 1d fans were quick to joke
that the royal couple named their son
after Louis Tomlinson and the 26 year
old singer is offering to be a mentor he
tweeted young Louis welcome to the world
I'll take you under my wing lad but the
real significance behind Prince Louis
Arthur Charles's name could be dedicated
to his royal lineage Prince William and
Prince Charles both share the middle
name Arthur while Prince Harry has the
middle name Charles his father's name as
for the first name it's believed to be a
tribute to Louis Mountbatten who played
a key role in the relationship between
William's grandparents Queen Elizabeth
and Prince Philip
[Music]
[Applause]
you